Ugh, the game is gone.
There it is.
Oh, it's too small.
More, more, more, everybody.
Sad more, boo.
My title is a lie.
My stream title is a lie.
I said that I fixed it.
And I did.
Unfortunately, you can't really tell.
It looks totally fine for you guys.
Now doesn't it.
Probably looks totally smooth for you guys.
Now doesn't it?
It sure does.
Yeah, I figured.
it's okay and so basically for anybody who is confused I
there's a tweet I posted a video of the situation but in OBS
the game looks perfectly fine but on my side it's it's not
very laggy it's just enough laggy where it's you know it's
quite noticeable.
Can Bioshock be normal for five streams?
It's so...
I am playing in windowed mode using lossless scaling.
So basically how I fixed it before was...
Let's see.
Maybe.
No, it's still laggy.
Basically, all I did was I adjusted the resolution And it
worked.
And then...
I clicked out of the game to set things up on my end and
clicked back into the game.
And it was all...
It was all...
laggy again.
And...
Um...
I mean, I could try V-Sync.
Honestly, like, at this point...
No.
does nothing um and i look at this too i even went in and i
saw like the distortion and stuff and i was like oh my gosh
i was getting so like about that i i went through the game
and i i like tested stuff out i got killed by big daddy i
accidentally attacked him with bees um i can try the it's
still like it probably looks so yeah on OBS it looks perfect
for you guys for me oh my god oh
I mean at the same time part of me is like I don't mind
playing like this where do I have that blood come from if uh
you guys can see okay but four and a half months of job
hunting i got a new job congratulations josh um but let me
try full screen let's it will mess things up but uh i can
just do my best to fix oh
my game disappeared wait uh uh it did this earlier
Oh, my game is, oh, uh, wait, did I, did I turn it on
windowed mode?
Oh, I think it went, I think it reverted back.
Um, okay, so it's actually smooth now.
Wait, this might work because it doesn't do the mouse thing.
This might work.
Now let me hope that, okay, it's in windowed mode, so I
might be able to, okay.
I had to turn off lossless scaling.
One second.
I don't want to change my display resolution, but thank you.
It messes with everything else on my screen.
Why am I...
Where?
How do I make...
Oh, how do I extend myself?
Very cool.
I hate having to troubleshoot on stream.
I'm sorry, guys.
There we go.
Let me move you guys.
Here.
Oh, I don't even think I tweeted.
Did I?
Who knows?
No, I don't think I did.
Okay.
It really throws me off my groove, you know.
When...
I do my best and things go crazy but it is playable like
this
yes oh it's now the same what you see what I see they are
the same yippee okay We are back, I think.
Thank you for the super chat.
Now it...
I'm like, dude, I'm testing my cursor.
It does not go out of bounds.
Yippee!
Yay!
Yay, and then watch this.
Wait.
Oh.
Not that.
Where did he come from?
I've been standing here the whole time.
Watch this.
Remember how...
When I go in the water, it does the fun here.
Not anymore.
We're cured!
We are cured of...
I thought I heard somebody.
We're cured of the distortion.
Like...
Oh.
Oh, I did hear somebody.
Bees.
Good job, bees.
Okie dokie.
Where?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, is that big boss?
Not big boss.
Oh, my God, big daddy.
It's a big boss.
I don't want to aggro him.
My brain immediately went to boss.
I also, I got like crazy attacks while I was like lagging.
I was testing all sorts of stuff earlier.
Wait, all three of my photos are messed up.
What happened?
We are on to one last guy that we need to get.
Stream is now true to its word.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
Big boss.
But I don't know where he is.
Hector Rodriguez.
I don't know how to get to that guy.
Do I have to go through the frozen tunnel?
Maybe?
I go back through there.
Wait, how did I get...
Oh.
Did you just say none of these other chumps will talk to me?
I wonder why.
None of these other chumps will talk to me.
Finally, Minto can take down the one guy to him.
Bees come back to me.
Bees?
Actually, no.
Bees go that way.
Bees go this way.
I just want to know who designed this map.
Oh, did I go in here?
Oh, or...
I'm realizing I don't know if I did.
Coffee.
I'm drinking that right now.
Maybe I... Is this what...
Do I need to be in here?
I don't know if I should be in here.
This feels new.
Yeah, I think this is new.
Unknown item.
watch.
Wow.
Okay, let's over here.
Oh, the doubters.
Them.
Hello, Minto from Canada.
Hello, Canada.
The doubters.
Oh my god.
I almost died.
One HP.
Holy cow.
That was scary.
That was pretty bad.
Can I even...
Oh, there it is.
I think I got it.
Oh, no, it didn't.
No, it did not.
Is this a trap?
Is this even worth going over there for?
There has to be something, right?
Oh, John.
Saving!
Oh, not going backing.
Saving.
There better be after all.
There has to be something, right?
Alright, alright.
Tube.
Oh, yeah.
Give me more pipes.
Yeah, baby, yeah, baby, yeah, baby, yeah.
This is solvable.
You wouldn't do that right, game.
You wouldn't give me something that's not solvable.
You've never done that to me before.
Oh, I thought I was pressing.
Did I hear someone whispering?
Singing, perhaps?
Oh, these are safes!
Oh, all three of them!
No way!
What?
Crispy creates happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Wait, this is the mother of all omelets.
This is...
This is my bee.
Oh no, I'm gonna be here for like the next half hour
probably.
Oh shoot, um, shoot, shoot.
Okay, we lost already.
But at the same time...
Bees.
Are you throwing things at me?
You're going to get bead.
You will get bead.
I wonder if that happens every time I fail.
Look at the shark outside.
I really could have used your help there.
Actually, I think they would have shot me.
Get bees, bozo.
Exactly.
Is there another one?
No?
Oh.
Nope.
Another timeline where Minto played OG Bioshock instead of
Remaster.
I wonder what kind of issues Minto have with that.
Who knows?
What is all this?
There's like so much, so many sound effects.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
You know...
Guys, for the sake of...
I have...
You know, I'm still kind of...
I'm very frustrated.
I'm really disappointed that the game was giving me issues
because I didn't get nearly as far as I wanted to yesterday.
The last time I played.
So I'm thinking...
I'm thinking we...
auto-hack these that's it one dollars is it because is it
because i auto-hacked no way literally one dollars i like
it's offensive that
that it says dollars when it's literally one oh which coffin
are you in here are you in there
um oh come on wait wait wait wait i'm so used to it like
being a thing right here this you know what I mean?
Freak off, you!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that, but that's okay.
Dang it, I didn't want to waste it.
Because I knew...
Wait, uh...
No, please, please!
Oh, this is my last run.
No, no!
Oh, sure!
No, no, no, no, no, no, that's even worse.
I'll take this.
More money.
This one doesn't say extremely hard.
No, I need that.
I need one.
This one.
Thank you.
Yay.
All right.
Save real quick.
Game's mocking me.
I feel a little bitter.
I'm not gonna lie.
Which sucks because I do enjoy the game.
I have so much fun.
Honestly, I don't know where to go from here, though.
You guys around?
There you are.
Ah!
Increased damage.
Bouncers are vulnerable to armor piercing.
What's a bouncer?
Oh,
there's a guy there.
Uh-oh, wait.
I don't want to get him with my bees, though.
Or my anything.
Oh, yeah, you guys fight.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is perfect.
Whoa, why is the lighting like that?
Yeah!
Action short!
Is he dead?
Someone's coughing.
I think I need to go into the Poseidon area, but there she
goes.
I'm just gonna run back.
Oh my god.
Why I thought he killed you?
I'm ready for dream.
They're not coming in here, are they?
Back to bees.
I need you to know circuits of value, not values.
So the remaster cuts the best lines from them.
If you leave without buying anything, it says come back when
you have some money, buddy.
That's kinda cute.
It says values with an S literally right there.
What are you talking about?
Circus of values.
Unless it's a dollar sign.
It says values right there.
Are you gaslighting me?
What does he say?
Hold on.
Once I hack this.
What the?
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
Oh.
This is...
This is why I save.
Voice says value, but sign says values.
I think then the voiceover is wrong.
I think he made the mistake.
I think he messed up.
Oh, come on.
This one's also not solvable.
Unless I started there.
I'm apparently illiterate.
It's okay.
We all have that moment.
If we could just speak to us.
Well, here.
I'm sure he says value.
Right?
Probably.
Shh.
Oh.
I need another long boy, please.
I need another long boy.
I need another, uh, or screwed.
There he was.
Voices values?
It does.
I don't know.
We'll have to really listen to him.
Okay, this could be fine.
Oh, yes, here we go.
Okay.
Yes.
And if I could get another long boy, please, thank you.
Yes, and then you, and then you.
Can you imagine if they wouldn't do that, right?
Have that one be a thing?
I think he says values.
I think it's a soft, it's like quiet.
He says circus of values.
I think it has an S.
It sounds like values.
I don't know.
Wait.
Kill your cravings at the circus of values.
He says values.
I'm sorry, man.
I don't know what to tell you.
He said values.
values.
I hope you don't feel too silly right now.
That was pretty bad.
Honey?
Oh my god.
The bees.
Honey, I'm a star.
Sometimes they're...
No, no, no.
Bees, come back.
Bees, don't go over there.
Yeah, bees come back.
Bees come back.
Bees hang in the area.
Bees were not moving.
Bees?
Bees.
Don't even look at him.
Don't even smell.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shit.
No, no, God.
No, please.
No, no, no, please.
No.
It wasn't B.
It was the bees.
Maybe he doesn't care.
He cares.
You don't even have a little sister.
I don't care about you.
I'm going in here.
And I'm hiding.
He won't see me.
He cares immensely.
I think he forgot.
Um.
No, he definitely cares.
No, no, no.
No, wait.
I swear it wasn't me.
Where is he?
Ah!
What did he do to me?
I got sunlocked.
Okay, let's just go this way.
This is the way I think we need to go anyway.
So we're fine.
Oh, shoot.
We're not fine.
Oh, we're not fine.
Oh, we're really not fine.
I don't want to take him on.
It's a waste of ammo.
You know what?
No.
I have circus of value.
You, I'm on you.
a long boy.
Oh, yian.
Uh, wait.
Uh.
Wait.
Oh, you.
Yeah.
Hack, hack.
Everything is fine.
We're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Or anything.
Um, maybe actually we go up and around here.
Okay, this is gonna be a little bit awkward.
Bear with me, bear with me.
We're going a little...
Okay, good, good.
Bear with me, okay?
I don't know if I have enough long boys, so this is why
we're doing this like this.
Okay, bear with me.
Okay, we definitely didn't have enough long boys, I think,
to reach all the way, so...
You're bearing, you're bearing.
Okay, I think we found the police.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm saving.
What a mess.
All right.
I'm all bees up.
How do I get down there?
Is this a sexy club?
What happened?
Come here, Tiger.
Uh-oh.
Actually, I guess this works.
It does not work.
Oh, my God.
No, shoot.
Uh.
Please.
What?
You give me an unsolvable one.
I didn't save!
I thought I would be okay!
Oh, come on!
Game!
Uh, well, I did save a second ago.
Let's just try again.
And then I'll heal myself or something, I don't know.
I'm just making sure this one is doable.
Okay, this one's doable.
Uh, nope.
Uh, I need another long boy, please.
Thank you.
All right.
This is scary because it's kind of giddy giddy.
Giddy giddy.
I played like a damn fiddle.
I'll heal though.
Okay.
Save.
The game like feels like it runs, it feels like new all of a
sudden, you know?
Maybe because I was dealing with everything early.
but it feels so good like it feels so different all of a
sudden the circus of value parentheses s oh what's in my
fortune what do you mean better luck next time he means you
have no future this one's a tough one I'll save again I'm
glad I think when games allow you to save like this you know
like in this oh okay we already lost sorry I was not fast
enough because like how do you say I'm so used to like older
games making it so that you once you enter an area, you
know, like, it depends, like, it's not like you save in the
very exact moment.
You save from, okay, we're good, we're good.
Oh, we're good-ish.
We're good- a good asterisk.
Okay.
All right, let's just, uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, yeah, yeah.
There we go, perfect.
Sub-Values...
Love it.
Machine gun round.
I'll buy some more.
Even though I've been using my shotgun.
It's okay.
We like to switch between stuff, right guys?
Void.
Yeah.
$4?
This place was about to go out of business.
Honestly, Rapture going up in flames.
Maybe help them.
The owner's like, that what do i do you don't need to do
anything guy everything's gone to heck everything's gone to
hail three too many three too many three too many oh what am
i what do i see what's happening
hello is it oh here i thought you had forgotten about poor
jasmine but i am so glad you didn't I'm sorry, Mr. Ryan.
I didn't know.
I didn't know Fontaine had something to do with it.
I...
What?
What are you doing?
No!
Wow!
Pregnancy!
Ah!
That creepy Dr. Tenenbaum promised me it wasn't going to be
a real pregnancy.
What do you mean a real pregnancy?
Take the egg out once Mr. Ryan and I had...
Oh, I needed the money so bad.
but I know Mr. Ryan's gonna suss it out.
Gonna know I wasn't being careful.
Gonna know I sold the...
Mr. Ryan's gonna be so mad at me.
She got that fine, Jin.
I guess I really didn't need to drink it, but...
Somebody's hungry?
Tummy rumble?
Right?
Wow, she's got a nice room.
She's got everything.
everything in there.
Maybe this isn't... Oh, she's got a safe.
Oh my god, she's messed up.
Okay, hold on.
Let's hack this bad boy.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Yeah, we just chugged it all and it gave us literally no
benefit.
In fact, it hurt us because it took our Eve.
But who Who cares?
You know?
Oh, I was too late.
I had nothing though!
I can only do what I can do.
Oh, okay.
Wait, this is kind of lucky.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, please.
No!
Oh, yes!
Not like she's gonna use it now, or anybody else for that
matter.
Heck you.
So, this all happened within the span of a couple days, but
like...
Like, how...
Like, surely people were going a little crazy before then.
No, I could smoke the pipe.
People were going a little crazy before then, right?
Like... Oh, I didn't take a picture of her, can I?
Ma'am?
Nope.
Oh.
Nah, that doesn't matter.
Her feet?
You sicko.
I'm not gonna take a picture of her feet.
I thought it was years.
Oh, I think the last time I asked, people were like, oh
yeah, this all happened.
In a couple of days.
Oh.
He's gonna do something!
Oh, he's gonna do something!
He was slowly falling apart through years.
Okay, that makes way more sense.
Where is he going?
Hello?
Wait, where is he going?
Um, I guess I gotta follow him.
Uh-oh, watch out.
Watch out for them.
Oh, where'd he go?
Mr. Bing, bing, bing, bing.
Oh, he's just taken off.
Hello?
Oh, please.
He's melting the place.
Where are you going, Mr?
I probably should use it.
Uh-oh.
Different gun for this guy.
Oh, oh, oh.
You know what?
Oh, ouch.
At least they tell me where he is.
Oh my god.
Wait, this isn't him, is it?
No.
In here?
I can't go in.
What the heck is this?
this?
A mask.
Oh, it might be his.
That's why I like my pistol.
It just exploded.
Nice shot, thank you.
Alright, that's our last guy.
I do believe.
Yeah.
It shows up so clearly.
Thank you, sir.
Alright, I hear some guy over there, so we're gonna...
My bees barely affected them.
Oh, am I going the wrong way?
Is it around this way?
La la la la la!
Backtracking a little bit, but that's okay.
Am I gonna get ambushed again?
Let me save.
Oh.
I love my bees!
Are you talking?
Are you talking to me?
Oh, I think it's an ad.
Skipper, skipper, skipper, skipper.
These come back.
Hashtag skip ad.
Oh my god.
Let's just do this.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Don't get your suit wet.
A bald spot, though.
It's kind of messed up, though.
This is beautiful.
It is.
Your final path to Orion is now coming.
Sandra say hello.
Are you saying something?
Are you talking?
You may avail yourself upon one of my lesser works as a
token of our time.
I can?
What's that?
If you had become my one and true disciple, you might have
been worthy of seeing inside...
There's so much happening.
Oh, we got it.
What is that?
I'm just gonna take this.
Yeah, where did the subtitles go?
I don't know.
I can't hear him at all.
He's talking about...
me being a disciple or something oh uh medical expert too uh
first aid kids give you more health we'll just store it for
now go what happened to you
go we can kill him but i don't want to do it there's a lot
going on we're just gonna leave I'm just gonna...
We're just gonna get out of here now.
I did super not worth.
Is he like super annoying or something?
You have not rescued or harvested any little sisters on this
deck.
You need Adam to...
for them to become more powerful.
You should not leave without getting more...
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
Cheers!
I was mad at me.
I don't know what is triggering the alarm.
Let's go figure it out.
Oh!
Oh, I think I grabbed that!
I grabbed that earlier when I was testing.
And I think I...
Sorry, I'm just gonna...
So I don't have to do it again.
I think I...
He had loaded a save and didn't grab it again.
The alarm is just going nutso mode.
Oh, it's finally stopped.
I can't unlock this.
Does it give you the key if you kill him?
To...
Okay.
Alright, so he's upstairs.
They're right...
here this is like a terrible area though because because
it's so open he could shoot me everywhere hmm the game is so
mad at me no there's not much cover at all this area is
serious tough like I could just run around but it's It's not
much like...
Ooh, I just realized I...
The mines.
It might be...
It might be mine time.
He's a bouncer, so no gun.
Oh, is that how it works?
Oh!
Is that how it works?
Oh, that's why...
So I didn't realize they were both different.
Okay.
So maybe...
Wait, I gotta aggro him.
Okay, so let's do this.
Wait, no, uh...
Don't leave.
He can't get up the stairs.
You can do it!
Wait.
No way.
Ah!
The little ones have never had anyone to look to, except to
me, and I am not much to speak of.
You give them hope.
And for this, I am grateful.
I'll send something to demonstrate that gratitude.
Oh!
It appears!
Yippee!
Replace...
Big...
Hypnotize Big Daddy with Hypnotize Big Daddy 2!
Yahoo!
And...
Oh, nice!
Epic combat.
He almost survived the cheese.
We did it!
I'm so sorry.
I wonder...
Should we get Incinerate 2?
I've been using Incinerate a lot or use it, you know.
so we could get that.
I think, honestly, Electro Bolt 2 would be really good so
that my me...
What's the word?
Chalking and hacking is longer.
The timeline, spoiler free, is about 20 years of rapture.
Became habitable in 1946.
Finished in 51.
Things started sparking in 58.
Got super bad in 59.
We show up in 68.
Oh!
Okay, thank you.
That's a good time.
That's a good spoiler free timeline.
Thank you.
Yeah, so I think we'll go for Electro Bolt and Incinerate.
And then what we could also do is get another slot for
something.
Or we could do two health.
We could do health upgrade Eve upgrade.
Hmm.
Incinerate combos with bees.
That's crazy.
There's still two other sisters to rescue.
That's true.
Amazing.
Mission completed.
That right there is why you're the best, boys.
You need to upgrade more than the slot.
for the health or the eve I
wish I could see hold on let me save real quick after we did
that amazing spectacular performance um and let's find um
um I don't remember where it is.
The gene bank.
Is it over here?
Yes.
Now the thing about engineering is I don't even have so
many.
Honestly, I'm fine with what I have.
Especially because...
I like hacking the way it is right now.
the combat one because we have the fire and we could also
include the ice.
What's this one do?
Photographer's eye I think is really good to keep.
Armored shell I think is really good to keep.
And then we could do, we have like static discharge tool
could be good.
You're already a top of the line hacker.
Yeah.
I would say so myself.
I don't want more haunts on hacking.
I do not want more mods on hacking because I enjoy I enjoy
how tough it is the way it is now so I do not want more um
yeah this is the one where it's take less damage from cold
and then we could have less damage from fire how often
though do we encounter I feel like fire is we encounter more
than cold so
the fire damage combo with fire ammo is crazy too yeah
that's why I use Inferno because of the fire.
So we'll just keep this.
Because I have more damage.
I use Inferno.
With it.
So I don't quite see a reason to get another slot right now
for combat.
For this.
We have more that we could do.
Like a medical expert.
Security invasion.
Insecurity in there.
Blue's Clueless happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy 21st birthday!
I hope you're party hardy and responsibladi.
Happy birthday!
If you hack, do you need a medical expert?
Um, I mean, yes and no, right?
Oh my gosh, Plumbas, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
So many birthdays today!
Happy, happy birthday!
And we have Eve Link Plus.
Security evasion.
Well, right now we'll stick with Scrounder.
But then, actually, turrets take longer to see you is kind
of nice, too.
Scrounder is nice, but I feel like it doesn't work very
much.
Like, I feel like it'll be empty and I search again and it's
still empty.
Or it'll be like one wine and I search again and it's one
wine.
So maybe it's better if there's a scrounger too.
Yeah, so I think security evasion would be better.
And so that's why I also see, like, I don't necessarily
need...
I need another slot here.
And then...
Security bullet creatures.
Oh yeah, I forgot about.
I think I... Did I buy this?
Are those pesky security cameras or getting you down?
Simply attack your enemies with your photoelectric insects.
Those cameras and turrets will become your best friend.
Wow, that mine kind of nice.
Oh, the game gave it to me.
Okay, okay.
Scrounder's kind of disappointing.
I have telekinesis.
equip.
I don't use it very much, but it is nice to have on hand
just in case I want to get an item that's out of reach.
But everything else I use.
I use a big daddy hypnosis.
I use incinerator.
I use bees.
Everything else I use, so... I don't know.
I feel like at the moment, getting that Eve upgrade and the
health upgrade aligns best with where I'm at at the moment.
You know what I mean?
So I think I'll do that.
I use bees.
So.
I think if I had like other, you know, there's, if I had
like some crazy good things in here, like I'm not going to
use hacking, actually.
I could use...
Two fewer alarm tiles and two fewer overload.
do have the one hacking thing on right now this one would
actually be probably pretty good to get but if we get the
other little sister i'll get this one and we'll swap it out
but for now health upgrade eve upgrade
oh are there they said there were okay so we got one where
the other well actually i know where the other the one is uh
no let's all right no bees wait it'll i switched my order
again oh my gosh okay f1 is now bees wait what is okay f3
why did it change my order that's so confusing what the heck
the b button very important
They joined, hoi mito.
Looks like you got a fix from yesterday.
I did, yeah.
I think you can rearrange them.
Is it at the gene bank that I can rearrange them?
Let's see.
No, see, it's different here.
I don't know.
I don't get it.
Why did it change on me?
it's so confusing okay so back through here
was another big daddy with
I can't believe I wasted those two proximity grenades though
that makes me a little sad
alright let's save it in here but it is what it is I think
you have to remove them and place them back to fix Oh, okay.
Well, if there's one around here, I'll do that.
Oh, wait, which one's fire?
This guy's love crawling on the ceiling.
What plasmid is that?
Too bad about the bomb or the mines, but the cheese is
hilarious.
yeah it was good all right um for big daddy
can i shot oh look we could try incinerator but all right
let's try and find him first
what's in here oh oh oh oh oh three oh my gosh
The dog is in the window.
Did I save?
Oh, whatever.
Get that dog in the window.
You hope the dog's for sale.
Is there another long boy?
Oh.
Oh, okay, wait.
Maybe we can do this.
We have time.
Yes.
Save.
how much is that doubt wait this this is so like it feels
like the nurses or something from silent hill you know oh
freaky uh get in the window
oh i don't have it anymore use the switch?
Oh gosh, what does that mean?
What is gonna happen to me?
What's gonna happen if I use the switch?
What happened?
Um...
Uh...
The door?
This one?
Oh!
Uh,
maybe we, uh, don't use, maybe we go back to bees.
This area is kind of scary.
This area is spooky.
Okay, let's hack.
Let's hack, baby.
And then also we get a weapon upgrade.
That's exciting.
Ah, get in the window.
Oh, I didn't get one.
Oh, you, you.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, dup, dup, dup, dup, dup, dup, dup.
It's okay.
This is gonna be stuck in my head, I fear.
How much is that doggy in the window?
I've never heard this song before.
Have you guys?
Do you know the song?
Please, long boy.
Long boy.
Yes.
Can we get a long-haired Minto for this?
the rest of the stream.
Just say if you don't like how I look.
Just say if you're like me and you're ugly.
Oh, I have too much money.
Okie dokie.
Let's do...
I think my grenade launcher for so that we can...
We'll do the damage increase.
What is damage immunity?
auto-generated sharp shape charges make you immune to the
damage oh wait that's huge immunity from my own grenades
immunity from my own grenades so you could go point blank
hell yeah i do want to do the damage increase because
honestly i felt like i was not doing so much damage to big
daddy when he was like cheesed on the when he was reason but
that means if i walk over one i would be totally fine though
hmm rocket jump ah that one's tough this one's tough to
decide i think the immunity is like op though immunity just
sound like itself sounds crazy but at the same time i've
been like I've been I feel like I've been pretty good about
shooting from a distance no so I think maybe the damage and
then I will go for the immunity yeah we'll go damage
I'm sorry
he scared me
he scared me I got a little frightened.
That was spooky.
That was actually spooky.
Yeah, I know I didn't get the immunity upgrade.
Honestly, I just shot without even thinking.
I just shot without even realizing what I had in my hand.
I can't take any of them.
You know, you put baby back in the corner.
Are they all awake now?
Aren't there more?
Are they all gone?
Oh, that's freaky.
There were more.
They're all gone now.
Ew, they're all gone!
Ew!
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew,
ew.
I'm sorry, this is so scary.
The game becomes a lot less scarier once you realize you
have gun and magic.
But at the same time, they're spookies.
Okay, bees.
Maybe they just disappeared.
Okay, we have to go find Big Daddy.
Oh, I found him.
What is down here?
I don't think we've been down here before.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Anakin room what the hell was this area used for there's a
thing over there oh my god
okay it's not like a weeping angel ah beast oh my god
Oh my god, so scary!
So they're just gonna start appearing around me now, huh?
Oh my god.
I hate that.
I don't like that at all.
That one came literally from behind me.
This is so scary.
Bees.
Well.
I thought it would require more than one shot.
I'm assuming, though, that there is going to be a limited
amount, the same number that was in the room.
Renaud, right?
You know?
Honestly, them ambushing me down here is better than...
Extra nutrition.
Make your food even healthier.
do extra nutrition too um i'm okay for now oh
my god not load save
i know they're gonna come from behind me
anyone else i have to use the little ghosty's room zap the
water that's what i got up here for
anybody in here we could try no one else brand the elephant
thank you so much for the gift thank you all right
i'm scared of them showing up behind me
this part's pretty spooky i'm not gonna lie i'm quite i'm
quite frightened i don't know i don't know how many there
are how many there will be and I have to hello and I have to
take care of this guy too look at all the content you would
have missed if you had left in the bathysphere I know
I have to be careful of not aggroing him while getting
stalked by alright here we go this seems doable let me save
though real quick before we
Stop, Mint, you're scaring me.
Am I looking around too erratically?
Uh...
Wait, no, don't go!
Oh, shoot.
I didn't even need to be them.
I'm gonna buy more stuff first.
I'm the Circus of Values.
Because I have too much money.
Okay, now we can...
Five more things.
Or take more money, rather.
You're going upstairs?
How many will there be?
Will they always be following after me now?
I sure hope...
No, surely not.
Once we leave.
Okay, all right.
Sorry.
Save.
Now we take on Big Daddy.
I'm losing the plot.
Where did he go?
You're not putting her away, right?
Bees.
Where did he go?
Wait, did I go in here before?
Oh,
cool.
Oh, my God.
Can we not?
Did I go?
I didn't go.
There's so much stuff I missed.
What the heck?
I just want to get Big Daddy without any interference,
please.
I'm ready for dream time.
Alright, proximity mine.
I'll go there soon with Mr. Bubbles!
No, no, no, no!
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Where'd you go?
No, no, no!
Holy shit.
Oh shit, oh shit!
Oh my god.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow!
Uh, let's go back to this.
Ouch!
Oh, damn.
I do love my pistol.
Oh, man.
Okay, rescue you.
No.
No, no!
Thank you.
You're welcome.
She tiptoed.
She really tiptoed around that one.
All right!
All right, all right, all right.
What's in the casino?
She walked right through it.
Back to BS.
Okay.
Wait, there was also...
All those... all the bodies here are gone now.
That sucks.
I hear a security camera.
Okay, I'll have to be careful.
Hell yeah.
Uh, what was it now?
F3?
Yes.
I can...
Get up there.
Can I get up there?
I can.
Oops.
I must have wasted it a little bit, my bad.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, jeez, oh, jeez, jeez, jeez,
jeez, jeez, okay.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I need another one.
Wait.
This is not possible.
You son of a gun!
Ah!
No, wait, no!
I don't, I'm not dealing with it.
I'm not dealing with you.
When did I last save before going in there?
Yeah, that's okay.
It's okay, we just take the...
Take the money, take the...
Oh, no fuel.
I'll save right above it.
Right below that.
I don't need hacking plasmids.
Shut up!
I'm gonna start banning people for telling me to get hacking
plasmids.
You guys are non-believers.
You guys are non-believers!
Why can't you trust the process?
Trust me!
If there's a will, there's a way!
Oh,
another gene bank here.
Okay.
Where'd he go?
Oh my god.
Oh, he's dead now.
This place is poison now, hasn't it?
Okay, I wanted to pick this up.
What was this called?
Bump cold pepper?
Oh.
That's like a hit, right?
Hot nose political operative?
We're talking about a dizzy twist what wrote a song or two
that got under Ryan's wig.
Huh.
And Minky we trust.
Yeah, yeah.
Trust Minky, trust Minky.
The bump.
What is this?
Oh.
Sure.
Give them any chance to die.
You know?
Okay, good.
We're fine.
Maybe we're okay.
Um, you.
Just hacking for the sake of hacking.
I...
Well, it's not even that.
I get buffs from it, you know?
Oh, I have too much Eve.
I do I do get buffs so it's not like I Like I get health and
I get Eve So it's not like I get nothing out of it But then
also there's the thrill No gods or kings only, Mickey Where
was that guy?
And we'll do the slot too Gamble Apple, apple, apple I
love the thrill of the hack oh wait wrong wrong thing oh i
have nothing oh gosh you know what it's fine
what for some reason i think it's gonna be more cash you
know i haven't used the what is it seven no i haven't used
this and i haven't used our crossbow Let's try it out.
Steel tip.
Trap.
Oh, trap.
Incendiary bolt.
I think I'm those two feet.
Oh, a hackable thing.
Shut up!
I know you're right, but...
I know you're right.
That doesn't make it any less wrong.
Any less offensive.
Oh, did that body just die?
Or...
Oh, no, there's one right there.
The white people are right.
They're running!
They're running around!
Can I like zoom in this?
Am I hitting?
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Not my armor piercing!
You made me wasted!
Ouch.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
You're right in front of me!
Oh.
I don't know where the third...
Um, I don't know where the third little sister is.
I think for now we're all right.
We can go to the next area.
We could come back if we need to.
Hey, Mary.
What's with the Sourpost?
Have you heard what's going on down in Apollo Square?
I hear they're putting people in cages.
I think the map shows you.
It doesn't.
I got got by this before.
Maybe it did in the original.
I don't know if it did in the original why they would take
that out, though.
Oh, wow.
Stupid head.
How do I get back?
down here
that's the safe one this area is oh here
it is so many bugs in the remaster they're all bees oh
that's not what I mean I have 80 let's go let me go get the
gene thing real quick sorry I forgot to do it before I ran
over here.
But I know where it is.
We could do it like two seconds.
He's dark.
Can I turn the lights back on, please?
In the garden, we are growing.
Hacking, hacking.
Hardly knowing.
Okay.
Oops.
Sorry, I forgot there was a vault in.
We shouldn't escape for a second.
We need live action, B-movie, and Bioshock movie.
I don't think the first one, I think, would be absolutely
terrifying.
Live action, B-movie would be really bad.
But a Bioshock movie, I think, would be really cool.
You have not rescued or harvested all the little sisters.
I know.
I'll come back.
Where am I going to?
This one?
Have four sisters?
I think a B live-action B-movie would be so bad.
The original trailer for this game was live-action.
It was sick.
Really?
I feel like this is a kind of game I think would work with a
live-action.
You know?
There are some games that you feel like could work.
Or knitting.
Or dally.
We get that from him, and we get out of this hellhole.
We're ghosts.
Way ahead of you, buddy.
That's just the mission is to go to the office?
Rap, I hear him.
The circus.
I see Cohen's lost his touch.
If you knew him, when?
When he used to believe in the work, in the struggle?
And now, he rots in that Neverland waiting for...
someone to come and tell him he still got it i suppose
that's why he let you live i know we're not close to the end
of the game because there were like two other
places we could go to on in the bathosphere what am i using
the phone for hello will someone pick up
smiley faces i do not see the circus It's of value!
Actually, no, I'll still save.
But, imagine...
Imagine...
Now that I have my new hacking ability, there's one less.
It might be totally doable without.
Look at that.
We're already hitting it big, baby.
Um...
Did I screw myself with this setup?
Oh, no, I didn't.
Oh, no, she's buffed.
Arcus Self-Values!
I didn't see anything with this, with the crossbow.
I don't know.
Maybe I wasn't hitting.
I have no idea.
I heard it's bad crossbow is the best this is why I don't
never know anything because I get mixed messages on
everything I get mixed messages on everything how many six
okay I'll do one more all right I think it has a zoom
function let me see Is it 7?
8.
What the?
Middle click?
Oh, it changes, oh, okay.
I thought only B changed it out.
Oh, neat.
Everything is both the best and worst thing in the game.
Yeah, I'm understanding that.
Z?
Oh, wait.
It's Z!
Okay, anyway, back to my shotgun.
So first this...
Just kidding, I'm bees, I'm all bees.
This I love...
Bees.
Holy cow.
Holy cow!
Oh, they're tough now.
They're like really tough now.
Difficulty spike time!
Yeah, I noticed.
Holy cow.
Gotta keep taking the pictures.
Okay, okay.
Where's that other guy anyway?
Oh.
Is that him?
See even a picture?
Action shot.
Oh, he's like...
Houdini.
Sounds like a whale.
Where'd he go?
Natural camouflage.
Need some peace and quiet.
actual camouflage, stop moving and just fade away.
That's crazy.
Maybe we do this and do it instead.
Ghost mode.
I do need some peace and quiet.
Not my armor piercing!
Look at that.
I've got invisible mode.
Whoa!
Wow, it acts so fast!
Oh my god!
I like the sound too, yeah, it's nice.
Blue!
Where B is maxing?
Office of Andrew Ryan!
Okay.
it feel not?
Like, I can't believe that.
I want to see the whale that I'm hearing.
Is that... Are those volcanoes?
Oh, my bad.
Are we still doing birthday?
Akasupa's.
Oh my gosh.
Deco Tom, happy birthday!
Is it your birthday?
Thank you so much, brother.
Akasupa, thank you!
You can taste it,
I'm tasting?
What am I tasting?
Bees.
I forget that they can still shoot, even when covered in
bees.
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot.
What was it?
F3?
Changed my whole thing around.
Alright.
We're hacking?
Ah!
No.
I'll do my best.
Sometimes the game isn't fair, though.
But I want to try.
Off my own ability.
Oh, can I get any long boys, please?
Yeah.
Whoa!
Longest way around ever!
Um...
Wait, I don't have a way that faces the other direction.
Wait a second.
Wait a second, wait a second.
Oh, wait a second.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
Oh, no!
I pressed escape to pause.
Ah.
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
Never mind.
Oh, nice.
But also not nice at the same time.
Okay, easy.
It happens.
It does happen.
It happens quite often for me.
Oh.
You didn't even do anything!
And you're lagging!
Tommy gun!
Be nice to him.
Oh, I got something.
What was that?
A diary?
he owns it now look stock and barrel for the good of the sea
he says you'll break it up in due time he says not resigned
from the council and lodged me letter of protest but that's
just pissing in the wind it'll be war eyesight unless
somebody stops Ryan I'm right fast so there's like oh you
know McDonough we see a lot there's a couple characters in
this that I'm like can I read wikis them or should I wait
until I play two because wait wait okay okay I'll wait then
because after portal I was like I went in and read so much
about Kate was it caveman Johnson or whatever I went in and
read a bunch about him and then I went and read a bunch
about Carolyn.
I was like, I want the lore.
Caveman Johnson, yeah.
Caveman Johnson.
Yeah.
Uh, this is not solvable.
You asshole.
I don't want to waste Well, it's fine.
We could.
Oh, I didn't get to read what the Super Chat said.
I'm so sorry.
What if we, like...
Oh, my God!
I need to, like, start doing stuff up here, but I also need,
like, you know...
Portal 2 lore is great.
It's so fun.
Caveman, John, Simon.
Okay.
You.
To...
To you.
To you, to...
To you...
Yes, I'm my love, to...
Oh, shit.
No, not shit.
To you...
Yes, I'm my love.
You...
I don't know if I have enough.
I don't have one that goes the other way!
Oh!
No!
I was out of I was out of options No, shut up, shut up, shut
up.
We're fine.
We're fine
It's to you I
Duna is the best part of the novel Bioshock Rapture.
He gets a lot of characterization.
Ah, cool.
Circus!
Values!
He does sometimes, I hear value sometimes.
I'm not gonna lie.
I do hear value sometimes.
75!
Pricy.
I'll buy it, though.
I'll buy it.
Oh, I didn't mean to do another save.
Caveman Johnson here, owner and CEO of Aperture Caverns.
He's like, Caveman, Caveman Johnson.
What's going on?
Oh, what's this?
Chemical Thriller.
What happened here?
Sometimes you ever, like, envy the people in this...
These sorts of places, you envy the people that are dead,
you know?
You're just like, ah, put out of your misery, you know?
What is this music?
Why is this music so scary?
Yes?
I hear a camera in there.
Grenade launcher.
Is she in there?
You're not going to come out, are you?
My health?
Oh, thank you.
I can't grab that, I don't think.
The circus?
The circus of value?
Oh, this is a new guy.
trying to get as close to Ryan's gate as possible without
making a spectacle of myself.
He's got a shield at six ways to Leicester.
There's no way into that place.
All I got from my trouble was the hairy eyeball from Ryan's
chrysalmates.
What's the reward you get for trying to outsmart the best
electrical engineer of our generation?
I got an Aussie now.
Literally everybody made their way here.
Literally everybody came here.
All right, let's hack some things and then go fight a lady,
I guess.
Oye, oye, oye.
The Barbie.
I will use that, yeah.
All right!
Oh, geez, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no!
That was cruel.
that woman
having to switch out the first thing is like so annoying
oh my god okay I get it I get it I get it I get it go up it
says go up I get it circus of values welcome to the circus
of I enjoy it so much, though.
I'm wasting all my...
How much film do I have planned?
I'll grab one more.
Take that.
Oops.
Oh, no!
I clicked E on accident!
Aw, man.
Oh, whatever.
Well, now I...
don't feel so bad.
Oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Just kidding.
I do urine for the heck.
That's pretty good.
It's pretty fun.
Alright.
All right.
Let's save again.
Now let's go fight this lady.
All right.
Cool.
I'm glad the game has been working so smoothly, though.
Let's go.
You think she'll care about my beat?
Oh, how many?
Three.
Three of them.
And a director's comment.
Yes.
Oh, uh, hack.
Hack.
Please.
Uh-huh.
Sounds sounds so much like Zumbinis!
Wait.
Oh, I don't think I can do that.
I don't have any...
Let's go around the other way then.
You...
Oh, I can't go around the other way.
Oh, well, isn't that just really dandy now?
Bottom right?
Where?
The thing that goes down?
What?
Where?
Wait, I looked at the bottom right.
What?
Why my head?
I didn't see it at all.
Otherwise, I would have grabbed it.
I went right past it.
That it?
Yeah, we go again.
It's cool.
It's chill.
Oh my god.
It's not chill.
It's not chill at all.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I would redo it if it wasn't the stinking alarm.
It's most certainly not chill.
I'm chilling.
Are you guys chilling?
Oh, wait.
Let me save.
We'll save right here so I don't have to keep, you know.
Yeah, we're chilling.
We're chilling.
I'm chilling.
Oh, shit.
Again?
Uh...
You.
What?
Heck.
Oh.
This is kind of fun.
Little bit of a zigzag going on it.
Oh, oh, okay.
Uh, fun.
Fun, fun, fun, fun.
We have so much fun here.
I have so much fun here!
I have so much fun!
I have so much fun all the time!
Mint is the chillest of flavors.
Exactly, exactly.
Cash.
We haven't had, I haven't had to invent anything in a while.
A fan Bioshock Deliverus or promise that it Mashes Prince of
Egypt.
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, okay.
Wait, how do I...
Actually, how do I...
Wait, oh, wait, you, you, you.
What?
That was stupid.
I'm hacking.
You know what?
I don't care.
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
Bloodlust.
You gain small amounts of health and eave when inflicting...
Oh, that's right.
Oh, yeah.
Hackers delight.
Two!
Every time...
I don't think I have two, do I?
I don't think I have two.
I can't remember.
Do I?
No you don't?
Yippee!
Electric gel.
For the chemical thrower.
Auto rounds.
And...
I'll even do another one.
okay cool
one's the bees one's the bees it really should tell you how
much you already I know I feel like I'm guessing I'm hoping
that I'm not like wasting supplies or anything you know what
I mean I'm hacking again I am once again hacking everybody
I'm A worm looks up and sees the face of God.
But look around.
It's a regular convention of worms in here.
They all had mothers, fathers.
Oh my god, there are people.
What makes you think?
You're any dude.
I haven't chosen the spot for you on the wall yet.
Let me know you have a preference.
Oh my god, well this one's free.
True, would you love me even if I were a worm moment?
There's a lot of people going on in there.
Everyone's yapping in there.
You didn't even...
You pinned them up here and you didn't raid their pockets?
Stopping Ryan!
Eat the glue.
Oh, dang it!
I had to go jungle style with that filthy ape for three
years.
weeks but he finally spilled the beans on how to get to
Andrew Ryan generate a sympathetic overload in harmonic core
number three hopefully it plays again now all I got to do is
figure out what the hell a sympathetic overload is and for
that matter a harmonic core number three piece of cake for
an electrical engineer too bad I designed ladies shoes gonna
go see the grease monkeys left alive in heat loss monitoring
see what I can shake out of their trees I like all parasites
who ever tried to walk in stolen shoes oh i'd explain the
science that is what you're trying to do impossible but that
would be like playing mozart for a rat row
i'm waited bees
he's got a gun so do you Where are they?
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot.
Where are they?
Ah Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
These guys are so tanky.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Are you doing flips?
I thought you were dead.
is coming back to life even now returning to her lungs the
shops reopening the schools humming with the thoughts of
young minds my bees where'd he go
bees why don't the bees attack him oh my god he's doing
styling on me ah I can't even I can't he has the best aim in
the world world.
Oh, finally.
Holy hell.
They're too good.
Why are my bees not doing anything?
Jungle styling on me.
Hit you with every shot mid-strape.
That's what I'm saying.
He is actually the best.
The aim in the world!
He doesn't...
He doesn't need to be here.
He needs to be in the Olympics or something.
In the gun category.
He'd be sick.
Rapture would win every gold.
The bees helped him lock it.
I know, he was like, ah, get these bees off of me.
Never mind.
Tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick.
Holy cow.
maybe
I only have two electric blocks you know what oh reliable
actually I only have nine erm hmm oh yeah let's take some
pictures of these guys they're all dead but it's fine the
Olympics is over oh is it really Can you give me more stuff?
Just gotta tap into your inner pain.
Yeah.
Nothing.
Of course nothing.
Do these count?
No.
Did I get this guy?
I think I did.
Oh, finish this past weekend.
Ah.
Well, he can join next year.
Or something.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's...
What?
I'm ignoring you?
I'm ignoring you.
Oh my god, we reached it!
We actually reached the max number!
Yeah!
Time to start at the very bottom, everybody.
Yeah,
we beat the game!
Oh my god, what an achievement that was.
what is the difference between a man and a parasite a man
builds a parasite asks where is my share a man creates a
parasite says what will the neighbors think what a man
invents a parasite says watch out or you might tread on the
toes of
My bees are not doing anything anymore.
Don't let yourself be frozen out.
Get Frozen Field 2 today.
Take much less damage from cold and can freeze enemies when
you hit them with the wrench!
Oh my gosh, the wrench build must go crazy in this game.
They're like, you're playing on hard mode, so we're gonna
give you everything that you achievement get.
Save goblin.
Maybe I should switch.
I'm considering.
There's a safe here?
Oh, it's right here!
Little baby!
Don't need to be so dramatic now.
Is this a special room or...
Wrench plus B?
Oh.
No!
It doesn't make me... It makes me...
Oh, no.
Okay.
fine we'll start like down here
your bees aren't bee-having yeah it feels like a you liked
using the wrench wrench build is bonkers solo wrench runs
are pretty easily done really?
oh shit I forgot it's a we're screwed we're screwed oh we're
screwed yeah
please oh wait oh
Oh, wow!
I did it.
Wrench is used for speed runs.
That's crazy.
Alright.
Save again, sorry.
Oh, and when it saves a new one, it brings it up there.
Oh, okay, cool.
Now I see.
Wrench is good for no money.
Well, if I get to the point, we could always just switch out
everything.
and uh use the wrench I don't know I could try I didn't get
a good look at this if will this shock me no okay all right
let's go in here I have to find core three
something oh my gosh that's a big daddy I hear a camera but
I don't see it in here so Are you okay?
He has a one single tube.
He's so sad for him.
Rapture is on the rise.
Alright, before I walk in here.
Get old.
Yeah, he's just taking a shower.
He looked so cute.
Like it made me want like a little plushy of him, you know?
We're at the core.
okay?
Where'd he go?
Can I check in here?
Why is the musical dramatic?
Bees.
Oh, wait, who are they fighting?
Oh, shit.
Uh-oh, wait.
He's gonna go aggro on me, I think.
I'm not here.
I love the way she encourages him It's so funny
Get him, Mr. B Get him
So good It's so good
Get him, Mr. B Yeah, my photo ops Okay, thank you Actually,
that's, this It works now that I can go invisible.
These wretched splices come streaming out of the poor houses
and stormed the proverbial barricades.
The dead rot in the streets and Johnny and Jamie's citizen
are lined up around the block for plasmids.
Anything to help fend off the rabble.
There's so many guys speaking down here.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
Is that him?
Is that a person?
No.
I need some good action shots, please.
Is this the guy he killed?
A peppy bar.
Oh!
That's pretty funny.
Okay.
Heat loss monitoring workshops.
Okay, we do need to go this way, though.
Let's go get it.
Oh, wait.
There's a camera.
Oh my gosh, no!
I'm trying to see if I can get a picture.
Maybe I can have the security camera.
Uh,
three.
Please?
Ah!
Wait.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Oh.
Oh wow, it just gets worse and worse.
Oh, it gets worse and worse.
Yeah, I'll auto-hack it.
Where is everybody?
They sound so close and yet so far.
There's so much going on.
Okay.
Oh!
Action shot!
That's not on me, right?
Some guys speaking.
This place is huge.
A family photo.
Oh no, it's a Houdini.
Yeah, but action.
Ah!
He's gone.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
That's pretty big.
There's a lot going on!
There's...
Yeah, he went somewhere and I'm not quite...
New Physical Tonic Extra Nutrition 3!
Okay, alright.
I think I'm good for now.
Where they go?
Oh.
I don't need to do anything.
So awesome.
I also like that I can use their organs.
Find Pablo's workshop in the heat.
Yeah, I understand.
Let's hack this.
There's so much going on.
Holy damn.
How long have I been streaming?
Only two hours?
My brain makes...
Wait.
Did it save?
No.
There we go.
It feels like I've been playing this game for a million
years.
Oh shit.
Hell yeah.
First try.
Who's speaking to me?
Oh.
Oh, he caught the whole thing on fire.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm getting lost.
I'm getting, like, lost in the sauce, you know?
Okay, all right.
We just...
I don't remember if I saved after hacking that, but that's
okay.
Um, so we go down to the heat loss.
Heat loss.
For now, we just follow the arrows.
Check the map of Little System.
They don't show up, you guys.
I don't know what to tell you.
Oh.
The music kind of funky.
That was scary.
None of these guys have anything on them.
I did just say before coming in here, right?
Yeah, it's fine.
They're making fun of me!
Wait, this is not...
Is this...
Oh!
Ouch!
Holy hell.
Oh my
god.
Ouch!
Let's switch to...
Just stand here.
Imagine the will it took to create a place like this.
And what have you built?
Nothing.
You can only loot and break.
You're not a man.
You're just a termite at her side.
Whatever you say, Mr. Whatever you say.
Whatever you say, Mr. Did I loot all the ones that woke up?
I guess so.
It was him.
I don't think anybody came over here.
I think we're good.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, the pictures!
Oh, yeah!
Sorry.
It's something I will never get used to, you guys.
I would just...
My brain is one way...
My brain is on or off.
I just won't remember ever.
So, don't yell at me in the comments.
that enough.
Did I take a picture of this guy?
Okay.
Oh, I admit, oh yeah, see?
What?
Okay, there we go.
Hugh Dainey.
Okie dokie.
Not trying to yell, just kindly reminder.
I don't mind the reminders at all because otherwise I would
forget.
So please don't mind, don't feel like you You are, I'm upset
or anything, if you just remind me.
Like I said, I'll forget otherwise.
I'm also...
I'm gonna...
Go to this one.
Some lovely music.
Is he walking around in here?
Oh yeah, he is.
How many are here?
Oh, three is.
I think I checked.
This is not the music I am used to for my circus of values.
This is too lovely.
Oh, not wrong.
There it is.
Whoops.
We're not gonna let that guy live.
What are you saying that?
Chocolate is what?
Chonkis is who?
Something is what?
Oh my god, he's shaking my camera so much.
Okay.
Wow, everything is so hard now.
I think this one is relatively easy, though, from what I
remember.
It's the safes that are the most difficult.
As long as the game doesn't cheat on you.
You know?
Usually you're okay.
Uh...
Alright.
I understand.
I must have a third one.
Oh!
Skinny Legend!
Skinny Legend saves the day!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
I like the music here.
It's nice.
Oh, you guys are being all sneaky about everything now, huh?
Aren't you?
Oh, where'd he go?
Oh, he died.
Maybe I should just let them die by fire.
Maybe I don't need to try so hard.
Oh, oh!
Wait, how do you do that?
What happened?
you was it me did i do that
purge them by cleansing flame exactly oh okay this is not so
ghost two to ghost one wait
oh my god he killed him oh there's his body right that's
crazy lore oh my gosh i'm hacking but it's like it's it's
for for the game it's not just for my own enjoyment it's to
continue imagine the poor sap who didn't hack at all before
this and isn't used to like you know how to do it oh my gosh
wait oh shoot oh oh i'm not used to how to do it actually
training made you ready for this i was i got pressured i
felt pressure
you know though they do actually like let you um auto hack
it though so i guess you don't really need to huh um i have
this yeah there we go okay it moves so fast i felt so much
pressure
You click so fast, because I'm on a speed.
Before the final rat has eaten the last gram of you, rapture
will have returned.
I will lead a parade.
Who was that, they'll say, as they point to the sad shade
hanging on my door?
Who was that?
he just he thinks he eats every time he's so annoying
genetics arms race i begged mr ryan to hand fontaine
suturistics over to amnesty's boys as a peace offering but
the stupid sod won't listen to the reason instead he's just
splicing his mob up giving them more and tougher plasmids
there's an arms race on here in russia but it's not about
who can it's about who can become less of a man and more of
a monster no I am the furia was that everything in here all
right I saw you I saw it it said storage crate for nine
bucks I'll do it give me the cash give me the cash money
security evasion too why let them know where you've been
lately the latest version of security evasion lets you
bypass any security camera or turret wait no wait oh it
takes much longer to see you what does that mean why is it
so like see you
it's nice honestly i don't think i've used my of having the
camel.
Willy poppies!
They can smell me.
Well, I showered.
You have to wave for the camera.
I have to do like a little dance, a jump, jump.
It's jump, jump, crouch.
Slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
Crisscross, applesauce.
Sit on the ground.
Hands down.
And everybody walks the dinosaur.
That's exactly what you have to do for the camera to notice
you.
Cha-cha, real smooth.
No, that's in Security of Agent 3.
Actually.
The camel does make me a lizard.
Um, well, hold on to it for now.
Store in the gene bank.
For now.
We can always pick it up again.
Getting a break.
Grabbing.
I like to grab everything first before I save and move on to
the next...
There's so many hoses.
Okay, so that's like our next thing to do.
Okay, cool.
Sadly, smelling nice still leaves you- See, it leaves me
detectable!
Pablo.
...
She was asking about magnetic locks and some such.
I played it coy, but she didn't rise.
After she showed me around her backyard, I gave her
directions to the shop.
Oh my god, please.
Oh shit.
But sometimes, the rain change still cuts you a break.
What?
What am I doing?
I didn't get to listen to literally any of that.
Oh my god.
You sucker.
I didn't get to listen to anything!
Go to Kaiverses workshops.
Okay.
All of that here to go to there.
So I just needed to go here to listen to then go to there.
Okay.
Can I grab their guns now?
I hear somebody like walking, walking.
Like heels and everything.
Can I replay it?
See?
Oh!
No, wait.
No, this is the old one.
The stupid sword won't listen to the reason.
Instead, he's just splicing his mob up.
It's okay.
I guess I just go someplace and we'll figure it out.
How do I get down there?
Wait, how do I get down there?
That's kind of fun.
Under the stairs.
Oh, the telekinesis?
Is she coming?
Oh, there's the gene bank.
What is this anyway?
I think it's stuff for the thing that I don't use.
It's fine.
All right.
Oh, I need to go this way.
We'll let the girls fight?
Oh.
Ah!
Where the hell did you come from?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
They scared me.
I didn't see them at all.
We're chill.
We just happen to have similar interests.
Yeah.
Go set.
Go.
That seems important.
Don't think so.
Oh, keyboard is his name.
Not keyboard.
Keyboards.
I put a couple of drinks in him last week.
And before I could say boo, he's telling me he's got the
code to his office keyed to the date of Australia Day.
Australia.
I slip in real gentle and nick a buck or two from the tail.
The Aussie never notices.
And I ain't about to tell him.
Seems like there's all kind of crazy stuff back there.
I'm American.
Maybe one day I'll get more ambitious.
Did I hack this values?
No.
Oh.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to do this.
What's Australia Day?
Oh.
Oh, I did hack it!
I'm stupid.
I'll buy one more.
Okay, let's go.
Running around with my camera out.
Oh, we're back in this way.
It's shocking.
on the same city in the middle of the ocean.
Mine, that sounds more like a middle.
Chicken jockey.
Alright, this area...
I remember, not this one, but in here.
The core is very confusing.
Get the sister, we'll get her eventually.
I guess that area is not so bad to get him in though.
Okay, this way?
Maybe I should try this thing though.
Liquid nitrogen.
We'll do the napalm, baby.
The timing this came out seemed unlikely someone would
record themselves describing their crimes.
You know?
Oh wait, I have fire.
though well what if we fire and then more fire that's always
fun i believe minto what i believe i'm not saying just
letting you know i believe it well thank you i appreciate
your uh you believing in me believing in me is a believe in
a good cause oh that's a that's a turret
Oh, oh my god, he almost got caught by me.
He would have regretted that.
He would have been like, oh!
Oh, he would have regretted that, I bet, probably.
Oh, I'm going this way.
Oh, here we go.
I don't trust.
Oh, I guess I can trust.
I heard it.
I heard it load up, I heard it load up!
I heard it load up!
The device?
Find the device.
Yeah, what is the device?
I would like to know.
We'll shock.
And then shot.
Got it.
The device, the device, the device.
Yeah, obviously.
Wait, there's a whole, there's a thing in here.
Let me end.
Is it, I'm not strong enough?
Telekinesis?
We'll try it.
Which one is it?
There's so many, you know.
This one, and they all keep, okay.
Oh, nice.
Alarm's going off for some reason.
Love that for it.
I got around.
Oh, hello.
91 days since our last accident.
Wow.
Is he blocking it or...
Where was...
Oh, there it is.
I think because I go invisible the turrets don't notice me
you know but also I do have the well no I didn't equip the
turret thing did I I'm hacking I'm hacking oh no I'm not I'm
crouching oh I'm hacking oh my god oh my god oh my god no no
no no no no no no down and then over over over over you and
then more over again and then uh again again again oh shoot
okay okay and then up and more up more up more up more up
more up and uh oh shit oh no oh this is why we this is why
we're so
I had no oppies.
That was a wild one.
I was struggling a little bit, but you made it work.
However we could.
I'm hacking.
I'm not hacking.
Hacking?
Hacking.
Why does it do this to me?
Okay.
Alright, alright.
You and a skinny legend.
I don't mind that you're a skinny legend.
I just need you to work.
It didn't work.
Uh...
Oh, yes.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please.
Where is it?
No!
Actually, it will go up and over.
Like that.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's so fast.
Okay.
You know, it's just so fast.
Oh my god, it's already started.
Okay, fine, I get it.
Uh, I need lots of, I need to go over lots of times.
Come on, you set this up for me, game.
You, you make it work.
Wait.
Oh shit.
I...
I don't know how to fix it.
Only...
Oh
my god, it's so fast.
It's so fast.
You really just gotta be like on top of it, you know?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Because it sneaks up on you before you even realize and then
you're like...
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Over, over, over, over, over, over.
And then...
Uh...
Over?
And then, uh, maybe up, please, yes, yes, and yes.
Oh!
We got it, we got it, you!
We got it, we got it.
Is this where I need to go?
A keypad.
That's how I would have done it.
What's in here, though?
Oh my god, it's so fast!
First try?
Oh!
I sure do hate that.
Australia Day.
What is- but nobody told me what Australia Day is.
Nobody told me.
I'm at a complete loss.
that didn't sound like a good sound that sounded like quite
a bad sound the dream what a bar me dream what a bar me
dream January 26 sorry I'm too busy playing the game but it
wasn't a tree really when I looked closer it was the core
control the gizmo that feeds the maglocks on Ryan's gate you
can't cut off the power comes right from the volcanic vents.
Ryan always gets his juice.
Juice.
We're drowning him in juice?
I like the sound of it.
Oh my gosh.
I think...
I'm just...
You know what?
I saved already, but I'm just gonna...
I healed on accident.
I didn't mean to.
I'm just gonna auto-hack.
I would enjoy the hacking more.
If I feel like still off today from getting frustrated about
fixing the game and then the game was like, no.
You know what I mean?
So, I have less patience today than I usually would.
I don't look good.
Here we go.
We're in time.
Yeah, I'm very glad it's working now and it has been.
Don't get me wrong.
Is that the device?
Damage research.
Get more bang for your research bug with damage research.
Carry your analysis further.
Now, what is this?
Increased damage bonuses gained?
What is research?
Is that, uh, photography?
Oh, it is photography.
Ooh, damage bonuses!
Oh!
okay which is we're gonna need to upgrade we're gonna get
another slot of this one well cuz I want to keep
photographers eye but we'll get a new slot this is this one
seems pretty good assembling the bomb one charge of nitro
glycerin in my office that will serve as the catalyst oh oh
past the circuit the bomb then a half can of ionic gel
that's the pretty betty of the mix should send the core into
compensation mode push power down the line and trigger the
circuit breaker on ryan's gate well that's the theory it'll
either work like a charm or above of rapture nothing
ventured wait i i don't want to play it right i don't want
to play it if i If I grab it, it'll play, no?
Oh my god, we're going to construct a bomb.
Oh, that's good.
That's a pretty big bomb.
Do not play it.
Oh, I don't have the components.
The items you need are listed in your journal.
Oh, you could have said that way earlier.
What do you mean?
Oh, that's a...
That's what he just said.
Just kidding.
Two quarter cans, ionic gel, one nitroglycerin charge.
Really?
It's called the R34?
Overload the core.
Finish the bomb.
She had this whole little area going on.
That's so sick.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
That's embarrassing.
permission to give randrew back his bomb denied did he come
in here no surprise she didn't run to oh look at that so you
oh wait we have to get them from no no surely not all of
them right do i have to kill big daddies
Unfortunately, the only source of our 34s are in suits worn
by big daddies.
Do you think they knew?
Do you think they knew what they were saying when they saw
Rota?
Do you think...
They definitely knew,
didn't they?
I think they knew something.
okay well good to know good to know cool awesome all right
let's go there was that one guy taking a bath it's so sad oh
my god we get launched here I
wonder If I could start, if I could get him, I wonder, hold
on, wait, do you think I can kind of cheese this?
You think I could cheese this?
Picture reminder.
Thank you.
Ooh!
I don't know where this guy is yapping from.
All right.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, tab.
No, take.
I thought tab...
No, shift.
Um...
I wonder if I could use, like, the trap bolt.
And, like, set it up, crisscross applesauce.
And then some mines?
I just have to do it before he...
Oh, wait.
Please, please, please.
What?
Wait, what happened?
Wait, what just happened?
The water?
You have to move out of the way.
What?
You have to move after shooting.
That's so lame.
The wire fires back at you.
Oh, okay.
Well, I think he's stuck again.
I think he is stuck, though.
So we have some time to set up everything real quick.
Oh, my gosh.
Take me home, Mr. Bubbles, as he's stuck in place.
But I'm afraid if I aggro him, he will be unstuck, you know
what I mean?
So we're gonna do...
Not the heat seeking, we'll do the proximity mine.
We'll do, like, here.
That does not as far as I thought it would be.
I think I'm gonna get him, though.
Oh, no, I don't.
Okay.
Alright, now it's like boom, boom, bam.
Maybe.
This might not work, but that's fine.
Oh, he's already like halfway.
Where am I getting shot from?
I don't know where I got shot from, but...
Uh, it worked.
Yippee!
Come here, little girl.
Easy peasy, yeah.
Yeah, he's dead, whatever.
That worked out really well, actually.
this guy i i can't stand him anymore you're welcome bye-bye
oh i already grabbed him elite bouncer it's so cool how many
do i need again sorry okay four so we gotta kill two more
guys it could be that that one guy taking a shower has one
too i don't think there was anywhere else
corpse you made it look easy I remember this voice line so
clearly because he won't shut up I know he's so annoying and
then we gotta find the jail and one nitroglycerin charge
let's he keeps it locked up in his office okay good to No?
Uh, isn't his office...
I observe all his commandments.
Isn't this his office?
Okay.
Um...
Is
it this one?
No, it's this one.
Hello?
Am I that bad of a shot?
Telekinesis, you can't?
I love how there's so...
There's so many things in...
Oh!
Even miles underwater.
He still sees everything.
She sees everything.
Wait.
I can't...
I can't figure it out.
There we go.
Ouch, out, out, out.
Holy!
That got me good.
I can't tell.
This is tough.
Another big daddy coming through.
Oh!
It got rid of it, though.
Nice.
Okay, I'm understanding how it's working.
Oh.
I'm understanding.
I'm understanding a little bit more.
Like, I can't...
Did that work?
No.
What the hell?
There we go.
This is
craziness.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
All right.
Throw a box or a corpse.
Oh wait, we do have this, right?
Wait!
easier.
Nice!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wow!
Oh, way easier.
There's a weapons upgrade in here.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, telekinesis makes this so easy.
Awesome.
It's just the one left.
Oh, the two left?
Three left.
The number left.
There is a number left.
I love number.
Yahoo!
Oh, if I just, like, walked up with the item.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, you're so right.
Intriguing switch!
Oh.
I will press the intrigue...
Oh, I'm sure it opens that up.
No?
Maybe?
Or something, perhaps.
And how intriguing this is.
Let's get the immunity!
Let's get the immunity down!
I think the other little sister is upstairs.
If not, we could do the same thing again.
of the more rare little sister lines really fully upgrade
three weapons let's go
yeah i'm pretty oh your faces are melted yeah i think oh i
think they're all upstairs no i'm getting this i'm getting
the nitroglycerin don't worry Don't worry guys.
I am scared though.
Okay.
Let's save before we press this because I know that is gonna
be... it's gonna turn into a hellscape.
I'm gonna use the napalm.
What the was that?
That did not turn into the hellscape that I imagined.
Yeah, I do have to get that.
Um...
It did kind of like just spawn the...
there now didn't it oh it came up on the ground that's so
stupid i won't get i won't forget the audio log don't you
worry oh shh oh my god i have nothing to turn to the other
way dead there was literally nothing
no oh no wait oh shoot i didn't realize it was going
straight into the alarm that's fine i can still grab it and
now i'm prepared for it to unlock i thought it was gonna be
a hoard here actually let's just get it first you know is
there blood in the streets of course have some chosen to
destroy themselves with careless splicing on the night but i
will make no proclamations i will dictate no laws Yeah, one
man army.
It is our impatience that invites in the parasite of big
government.
And once you've invited it in, it will never stop feeding on
the body of the city.
Alright.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, so it does...
It does...
How do you know?
How do you know I'm here?
Huh?
You don't know.
You don't know I'm here.
How do you know I'm here?
We have turned away from your life.
Grab that, grab that.
That's so funny that he's just like, ah!
Oh wait, let's save real quick for right here.
Stupid game.
We're hacking!
Oh, we're not hacking.
We're hacking now.
Okay.
All right, give me a, yeah, that kind of guy.
And then this guy, and then this guy.
Oh, yo, yo.
You listen to me now.
Is that everything in here?
I guess so.
Why, as soon as I step out the door, he starts freaking out?
Ran Drew Ryan.
Did I screw up?
Absolutely.
Did I ruin people's lives?
Undoubtedly.
Will I apologize for it?
What just happened?
I think he's aggroed on me.
Wait.
Wait a second.
I think he's aggroed on me for some reason.
I'm actually very confused.
What is going on?
Maybe?
Oh, what's going on over here?
Oh.
How do I get in there?
Is there like a...
Do I telekinesis it or do I...
Oh wait, it lets me search the storage grid.
Okay, he's not aggroed on me.
give me a smile big guy nice one more there's a secret great
yeah I gotta find it yuppie oh yeah all right let's get him
down here oh no no no wait wait wait wait I can do this I'm
running I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
crouching and I'm crawling I don't want him to do you think
he'll come back hello hello he's stupid he's stupid where'd
he go he
give up he wasn't aggro I could have sworn he was.
Wait a second.
Who's that?
Oh.
No, he wasn't aggroed.
I was too fast.
Well, at least I have immunity now, but...
Okay, can I get past this?
Let's try it.
I wanted the little sister.
I've tried to get him before.
Oh, he is aggroed.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I thought this guy doesn't have guns.
Oh, I think my turrets are going after him.
Is he dead?
No!
We got him!
But, oh man!
We didn't get a little sister!
He put her away already!
Ah!
Oh, that's so annoying.
Man!
Reload?
When did I last save?
Oh wait, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, we could because I saved right after I did this,
right?
So we can get him...
Ah, okay.
Alright, let's figure this out.
We do need another kill, but there's two other guys we can
get.
Alright.
Um...
I might have to be like really stupid about this.
They're going to come down.
If I shoot this, does it go through the stairs?
Oh, I don't want it.
That's stupid ass.
Yeah, we'll let him handle it.
Wait, is he mad at me?
I think I hit my thing twice.
Okay, alright.
This is so stupid.
Oops.
Um, wait.
Proximity.
Oh.
Wait.
That didn't get him.
Thank you.
Oh, he was already mid-animation again!
Ah!
Oh shit, okay.
Hold on, let me reload.
Oh my god!
Okay.
We'll get this, we'll get this.
Leroy!
I'm trying not to like...
I want him to go down the stairs just a little bit so I can
get him, but you know?
Okay.
Alright.
I got distracted by those two other guys that came to get
me.
Let's do the frag and then I'll run.
If I put the mine on here though, wait, let me see.
We can just reload if it doesn't work.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, it does work!
I'll do what you say!
Get him, Mr. Beast!
She says.
This place is kind of awesome.
This place is awesome!
I can just farm them here.
Alright, baby.
Little baby.
I'm sorry.
Now the hidey hole is goaded.
It is!
Oh, I should have taken the photo.
while he was running at me.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you for reminding me that the light of the world has
not yet been snuffed out.
I am sending a little one to help you on your way.
Thank you.
Is it taking care of that guy finally?
Oh.
Uh.
Wait.
Only making it worse for yourself.
Only making it worse for...
Oh, I think he just went to go heal himself and killed and
died.
But he didn't destroy the heal station.
He's just stupid.
Wait, how did that happen?
You're only making it worse for yourself.
Let's save since we just...
Oh, yes.
Oh, it gassed him.
Woo!
Alright.
Oops, not thing.
Let's see.
So we need one more R34 wire cluster.
We got the...
Oh, let's go put the nitroglycerin in the bomb.
Well, I guess...
Well, we can do it all at once, right?
And then the ionic gel you can find it throughout
Hephaestus.
Oh.
Awesome.
Two quarter cans of ionic gel to supply the electrical
charge.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Blue lava lamps.
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Peace.
I want to find the secret...
The secret.
hole to get under here.
I found the secret hole to get under here.
I found it.
I thought he was waving at me for a second.
You know, you're really freaking annoying.
This guy.
Asking your shower seed.
I'm going to leave where I ended up.
The damn farmer's market clear on the other end of What?
I fixed it right up and installed some new gasket.
What a mess.
Anyway, the code is 0512 if you ever need to get back in
there to do maintenance.
0512?
Where was it?
What was that now?
05?
For what?
These.
Oh, dang.
Anyway.
Now I'll take the...
We can buy some more stuff now.
I didn't hack any of these.
I think it's the hackable door here.
Thank you.
Somewhere.
Over here?
Hold on.
Let me buy things first.
Time to hack.
Again.
What's on that wall next to the ammo?
This?
Oh, this is if the alarms go off.
You can turn them off.
Money!
Imagine if, like, Snake were in there.
That'd be crazy.
Oh, oh, I hate this game.
We believe,
we believe, we believe, we believe, and this is why we
believe.
Into the circus of values!
I'll buy more of those.
I use these.
And I use these.
Now I'm going to go grab all the money that I missed.
From especially these big guys.
Because they always have big bucks.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
I was getting them out.
Kappa!
Thank you for the I'm good to thank you.
Oh.
Wait.
I was right the first time.
He does not have a little sister, but we could get the last
core.
Wait.
What if he's picking up a little sister?
He could pick up one.
And if that's the case.
Wait.
Say cheese.
Yeah, he might pull one from the van.
You're going to do that, right, mister?
no no do you guys you guys see that right
i didn't do anything i didn't do anything so for those maybe
if you didn't watch the other parts especially yesterday's i
have been having issues where the game is just the game
doesn't like to run in full screen or it's laggy or it's
something and then when I play in windowed mode I have this
issue where my cursor will appear and then like see you
can't tell but it's like clicking it's like over it's
hovering over other like windows and stuff oh no computer
said it's time for bed yeah so it's like very frustrating
because once this happens say i'm like in the middle of a
fight and i look up or something i might accidentally like
click out of the window and it's like yesterday it was
completely throwing off my game because i was like
constantly clicking out of the window and luckily it pauses
the game but it uh it just you know throws me yeah it's very
annoying and it kind of throws me off of my all right but we
will click okay no he's not picking up a sister why not why
don't you pick up little sister why don't you pick her up i
do like the red though it's very very cool
it's not happening when i look up though So maybe it was
just a fluke.
We will, we will try for now.
It could have been just a fluke.
I think I gotta get this guy though.
Oh no, he is calling little sister.
He's calling a different little sister!
Oh yes, perfect.
Hurry, hurry Mr. Bubbles.
Please, please, please, please!
Is he gonna come over here?
He exploded so fast.
Wait, can I get one more and squeeze a little tiny bit out?
Yeah!
Small increases to max health and Eve!
Cool.
Yay, we got all three!
Yeah, I gotta get her tears in the photos.
thank you nice wow we did so good you guys we literally got
two birds with one stone that was awesome nice I love my
hidey hole it's awesome
I think he's gone he's Mr. G Mr. gone um alright
okay now we got those we need just the ionic gels so let's
go find those why am i am i still crouch oh i accidentally
hit control it seems
oh i'm reloading
Why is styling on me?
How was that?
He was doing every flip in the world!
Oh my goodness gracious, so funny.
There's no...
There's
no...
There's no...
Nice.
Australia Day!
Oh my god!
You guys, did you know that Australia Day is January 26th?
Did you know that?
I bet you didn't.
Yeah, even the clown's laughing at you.
Oh, whoops, that's all I meant to do.
This way.
Oh shoot.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Ow, ow, ow.
Ow.
Oh my god.
How embarrassing.
Oh my god, there you are.
I didn't even realize you were there.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
Oh my god.
That's embarrassing.
Are you buying more?
Ah!
I should probably change my gun.
To not this.
there we go we're fine don't worry about it I have so much
money we'll just buy more
we're fine everything's fine guys don't worry about it
anyway what was I doing before that lady like snuck up on me
huh Oh, I did it.
Was there anything over here?
Or was it just a trap for no reason?
No way!
There's nothing here!
That's so lame.
Okay, it's telling me to go the other way.
This way?
I think this way.
Oh!
Safe.
Huck?
I'll use an auto hack.
Okay.
It feels so dirty.
Oh, nice.
Alright, remember there's frag grenades in here, guys.
Oh, there's one!
Okay, we got one out of two.
Easy?
Easy peasy?
Soda.
She hacks hacking.
Alright, so...
It was just two, right?
Yes.
I think maybe I need to go this this away this is the way
back to the big room that I don't like, right?
It's pointing me this way, why?
What?
Down here?
Oh, I think it's telling me okay, never mind, hold on, can I
change the objective?
Yeah, okay, change, there we go.
It's it won't let me change it.
Yeah, it's taking me to the bomb.
Okay, never mind.
Alright, let's go back in here.
We can ignore every Big Daddy from here on out.
Oh my god.
Err.
No way it was so easy.
Got some coffee to drink even.
Hi Big Daddy!
Bye Big Daddy!
I take your money.
Okay.
Yappy guy.
Yeah, we ignore him.
Alright, everybody.
Time to actually make the bomb.
Woohoo!
I'm making a bomb!
You guys, I uploaded a short about, like, a clover, clover
pit.
And I was like, yeah!
I even tried to...
What the hell?
Where did you come from?
Holy!
You were just napping on the floor or something?
What was that?
But I uploaded it, and YouTube was just like, nah, we have
to age restrict this.
We have to age restrict your short.
Oh, he was pretending to be dead to surprise me.
Eye on it.
I'm constructing.
Pick up the device.
Oh my god, there's another guy.
It doesn't look like it's a real bomb.
It's better.
You got to put it on the core, past geothermal control.
And we'll see if these needle noses knew what the hell they
were talking about.
Okay.
Mom's gonna show us since we already went through it.
Here we go.
I go to place the bomb.
Oops.
Awkward.
Where are you?
Oh, what do you call me?
Oh.
What do you call me?
Oh, awkward.
Oh, I'm running out of ammo.
I gotta go buy some more.
I gotta go buy some more ammo.
Is that a guy?
Or was that the thing?
Okay.
I saw a thing right there and I couldn't tell if it was a
head or not.
Let's switch to the machine gun.
Time to try crossbow.
I could.
I don't know I just didn't need okay I'll try it we'll try
it but I still should buy some more shoddy ammo right or use
a different gun I get so comfy oh not the trap bolt though
are you here where are you sounds like he's in here oh no
he's upstairs I'll do my Gosh, you guys are annoying.
Did I hack this?
No.
I'll try this one.
I don't want to like use all my... I only want to use my
hacking ones when it's... when it's absolute necessary.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
But this one's pretty slow, actually.
I say, now it's getting fast.
Never mind.
It's getting fast.
Uh.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
First try.
Wish it wasn't so expensive.
Even after you hack it.
It's so expensive.
Wow.
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh, this way.
Maybe the other lady that I was fighting was just so strong,
you know?
I'm following the arrow, the arrow, the arrow.
I'm following the arrow.
We go into here.
Looks like the ocean's got an edge to retake this corner of
Rapture.
this happened right after the start of the war read about it
the papers whoa head on in i'll see what i can dig up to
help okay thank you jeez bank invent bank frag grenade
what's the difference between going in here and going in
there follow the yellow brick road follow the yellow brick
road
oh come on don't be like this
Why does it say that it's easy?
Or easier than usual.
Oh.
Uh.
There we go.
Wow, it's so slow for some reason.
Oh, there's another one on the other side.
We got this.
Are you dead?
I'm no engineer, but if I read these plans right, you can
channel that magma flow using the redirect valve.
It'll boil off that water right quick, and you'll be able to
reach the car.
But Ryan's sure to take notice.
I want to set up a perimeter just to be certain.
What do you mean a perimeter?
Redirect the magma flow.
What do
you mean by these?
Is that why?
Are you serious right now?
Make traps.
Set up defenses.
You're an asshole.
Game, that wasn't very nice of you.
Especially for one that is supposed to be an easy one.
That was not very kind.
Okay.
Oh, there.
Yeah, not very cash and money of you, game.
Alright, so it wants us to set up traps of the such.
Oh, that was it.
Proximity mines.
I think I am... I think I'm picking up what you're... what
you're dealing.
What you're putting out.
I think I'm picking it up.
Okay, I have to go like completely all the way around.
That's really fun.
Thank you.
Okay, good.
Real fun game.
Real fun.
long boys to do we could go down and around and to town and
oh it's already done
hokidoki everything should be hacked now
so he wants me to do I call the elevator first or hold on
redirect the magma flow in order to clear the flood you must
crank the redirect valve until the interlock is fully
engaged this will redirect the magma into the lower levels
and should boil off the water okay so before we can go down
we have to get rid of the water but when I start turning it
people are gonna notice okay Yeah, so we gotta set up our
traps.
I wonder how bad I need to set them up.
You know?
This is a good time for me to learn how to use trap wires, I
guess.
Let loose?
Oh wait.
Oh, there it is, trap gold.
Are you for real?
I think I don't know how to use this thing.
Wait, where did it go?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Wait, how?
Nobody does!
Yeah, it deleted itself!
Can I...
Did I save?
I don't remember.
Wait, I can tell if I did.
Before I use up all of them, I'm going to make a new save.
Oh, oops.
Not bad.
Let's do this.
Try shooting the other way.
Like this, maybe?
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Wait, that was the only one I had!
Well, that's...
Fine.
That was something.
And that was all the proximity mines I have.
Yeah, maybe a spider will crawl on it or something, I don't
know.
A moth will fly attracted to the light.
Ah!
The worst part is the trap darts are so OP.
That's just hard to...
I...
It's hard to know how to aim them, right?
Okay, um...
I guess...
We'll hope that everything works in our favor.
Wait, I can't take photos while I'm turning, can I?
Well, that's lame.
We'll just do that.
We'll keep this on, and, uh...
Sure.
Here we go.
How long do I have to hold this for?
I did it.
I didn't need to use any of the other ones on this side.
But okay.
Sure, Gib.
So lame.
Oh, it says I collected a...
I wish I could take them back!
Man!
Every- all of my defenses!
You know what?
This is why you play bloons.
You play bloons so that you're good at the...
You're good at it, yeah.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Wahoo!
Ooh!
Wait.
Yeah, we'll keep this.
Can I fall in the goop?
Oh, yeah, you can.
Anything around here?
Nothing interesting?
No?
Okay, bring it to the core.
So far away from your family.
Oh!
Everything you have allowed.
But for some reason, you like it here.
and feel something you can't quite put your finger on think
about it for a second and maybe the world will come to you
nostalgia nostalgia zero zero trap wire carried yeah i
think i'm hearing the guy from up there that's all i need
maybe
city not my words your only reward will be a knife in the
bank you think are we gonna get betrayed but i don't know i
feel like i trust atlas it's hard to say though yeah place
the bomb
um should i back up
oh i need you to get out of it
Okay!
Hold on, sorry.
I'm just gonna save.
I don't want to have to run all the way back.
All right.
Alice is our friend.
Right?
Did he have it?
He did!
I was so right!
Uh oh, there's a timer.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I know your time.
Wait, where am I?
Where is...
Where the hell am I?
Where?
I'm lost.
Oh, I need to go here!
Oh, is it open?
Please!
Shoot!
Oh!
Oh, it killed him.
That's so handy.
Oh, no, it didn't.
Can you guys like not... Can you guys just leave me along?
Oh.
Bees.
I'm on my... Let's use this bad boy.
Wait, not that bad boy.
This bad boy.
I can't hear you over the guys that you've sent me.
Napalm.
It's absolute chaos.
Bees.
Napalm.
Why aren't the bees going?
Why don't they...
I think I'm getting...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Is this the switch?
What's the switch?
It's literally...
I'm just trying to kill the people first!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to...
Freaking...
bees and then oh my god anything that will kill them please
you're only making it is it this
get me out of here open up please oh we made it
i didn't see it why couldn't i do it from the other side
Holy cow!
Oh my god, I didn't think I was gonna make it.
Maybe I should reload, so I have like...
So I...
Maybe I should reload.
Now that I know...
Nah, I don't want to go through it again.
It's fine.
That's a game saved.
Yeah.
How many people could be in here?
It's your office.
I guess a lot.
Even in the book of lies, sometimes you find truth.
Oh, there he is.
For all things.
And now that I see you, flesh to flesh, and blood please my
hand against you.
But know this, you are my greatest disappointment.
Because you're master, hear me?
Atlas, you can kill me, but you will never have my city.
My strength is not in steam.
in fire that is what the parasites will never understand a
season for all things a time to live and a time to die a
time to build and a time to destroy who was there were you
okay fishies what
riots at the corner self-destruct this is different than
what uses he's got a mind to take down the whole damn city
get in there and whack the chunk for the whole joint blows
but like
okay one second one second one second
but the circus the values are calling to me you don't
understand like they have great values
You don't understand.
Like the circuit...
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is this...
This is not solvable.
Wait, yes it is.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, damn it.
I missed my chance.
Hold on.
I'm going to load.
Do I actually have a timer?
I didn't see one.
Yeah, I didn't see one.
We're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry, you're pretty little head.
About it.
Do I have another long boy?
Yeah.
The circus of values.
I'm quite concerned for my first aid kits.
We'll go with this.
Okay, so I have a thing here.
All right, let's explore now.
Ooh.
We're probably fine.
Client Orion Industries, stage one, each complete.
Sinclair and Alexander try to explain the science to me, but
Suchang does not believe them.
They keep saying, plasmid reconstruction, this, and the
quantum entanglement, that, and then prove that there's
people who have a better life.
Bullshit.
Oh.
Of course, Ryan will only allow it to be too many genetic
frequencies for the testing.
How about the chamber?
That's cool.
Um, nothing up here?
Alright.
Anything over here?
Oh!
We're fine.
Don't worry about it, everybody.
Don't you worry.
Can I crawl in there?
Oh!
Don't you!
Don't worry.
I know we're sideways, but like it's cool.
We're chill.
Everything's fine.
What's in here?
Uh.
Pretty dark.
Oh, I'm going.
Wait, is this how I get inside?
Does the door not open?
I mean, I didn't expect him to just leave it unlocked,
but...
Oh.
Cool.
Cool, all right.
I thought I heard someone walking about.
My trusty wrench.
I will save here, though.
Sorry, I know I just saved.
I don't care.
All right.
Randru!
Your time!
Has come!
Ah!
Oh, am I okay?
What is this?
No.
Dude, the music is so mysterious.
Recombinant series.
That's her mind control test?
Is it that your puppy?
She's very pretty.
Thank you, Papa Zuchon.
Break her neck first.
What?
Break that sweet puppy's neck.
I'm not looking at chat, by the way.
Am I the baby?
Advanced deployment, lot 111.
Dr. Su-Chong, client Fontaine Futuristics.
Baby is now a year old.
Ways of 58 pounds.
first mentioned it.
What?
I'm an adult baby.
No, I'm a literal stereotype.
No way.
Am I?
That's in my family!
I'm an adult baby!
Uh oh.
Uh oh, I'm an adult baby.
No.
Oh, I'm an adult, baby.
It's me.
So if you care to find me, look to the western sky.
As someone told me lately.
The assassin has overcome my final defense.
And now he's come to murder me.
In the end, what separates a man?
From a slave.
Money?
Power?
No.
A man chooses.
What is a mess?
A slave obeys.
You think you have memories.
A farm.
A family.
Life, not family.
A crash.
Yeah.
And then this place.
Was there really a family?
Oh my god!
Did that airplane crash?
Or was it hijacked?
Forced down.
Forced down by something less than a man.
Something bred to sleepwalk through life.
What an ugly baby!
By a simple phrase.
Spoken by their kindly master.
Was a man sent to kill?
Or a slave?
A man chooses.
A slave obeys.
Come in.
I don't want to come in now because I'm no slave.
I'm a man.
I'm a man baby.
Oh.
No.
I choose.
I choose to leave.
Wow.
Oh.
This is so ornate.
It's kind of gaudy.
Stop.
I have a gun.
Would you kindly Would you kindly get this?
Would you kindly head to Ryan's office and kill the son of a
witch?
Atlas!
It's my...
Oh my god.
Stand.
Would you kindly...
Run!
Stop!
Turn.
A man chooses.
A slave obeys.
Kill!
Oh, damn!
Oh my god!
Whack!
Whack him!
A man chooses!
I'm not even doing anything.
I'm not even pressing anything.
Have a nice day, would you kindly?
BAY!
Oh!
Defeated Andrew Ryan.
Would you kindly...
Atlas?
Atlas, you are not our friend.
How did you know that?
I'm robbing him.
How do you know this sleep rage and phrase?
Age for a hint of your suck.
I think it tells you that when you like have been lagging
too long.
Deactivated.
Why is it here?
Why is all this here, actually?
Oh, I can't even save!
We have to...
No, we don't have to risk it.
How does it know?
A picture?
Take a picture of him?
You're so right.
I wish I had done it when he was alive.
Say tease, Randru!
Oh.
No.
No good.
Maybe it only works when he's alive.
Oh, worth a shot though, worth a shot.
All right, here we go.
Is this really gonna...
work?
Oh,
I'm stuck.
Ah, Liz!
A very Chinese period of your life, huh?
It's Fontaine!
Name's Frank Fontaine.
Oh, he's bald!
I
like how there's just a self-destruct for the whole city.
What does a tits-toes mean?
Oh
my god
Escape Follow her Oh my gosh, wait, oh, that's a wall The
little sisters are my friends now I'm coming with you Oh Oh
Oh Is a Tenenbaum our friend because we saved the sisters?
Olympus Heights.
We're in her safe house.
Welcome back, child.
Welcome to the city where you were born.
I'm a literal baby.
You are angry at Fontaine, yes?
Yeah.
Now you know the truth.
Brought back to Rapture to save him.
You have saved many of my little ones.
Yeah, I did.
I owe you a debt.
Please, I undo some of Fontaine's mental conditioning.
His control is no longer complete.
But he can still pull some very unpleasant string.
I don't like that.
I don't like that part.
I'm a baby just like you.
Look how cute they are.
You have designed your mind.
Taunt Fontaine to control you.
You might find answers in such a way.
okay save yourself from Fontaine is the goal can't I just
stay here it looks so nice we can just color and hang out
yeah I hear somebody talking in there she won't let me see
her that's I don't think the smoking in there is good for
the girls health lady I think that's counterproductive if
you're trying to hurt nurse your back you know oh oh
oh yeah you the chosen child come with me They're
everywhere.
Oh my god.
The one who will save us all.
I like you.
You like me!
Where are you hopping to?
Girl, that's not where the hopscotch is.
You're lost.
You are lost.
Can I push it?
Oh.
I could push her back.
No, we can't.
It's the last.
She's the last guys.
Who's he?
He's here to help us.
They're so cute.
I wonder if this place would look different if you chose to
harvest them instead.
Oh.
I don't know if I can crawl through that.
I know I'm a baby, but I'm like really big.
Oh.
Thank you.
And we're...
Wait, my health and stuff is gone, though.
I still have...
Wait, where's my health?
Oh, there it is.
She was conditioned to play on her own rules.
A girl chooses a hopscotch real face.
But now, go get stepped on by a...
I'm not listening to you.
Oh.
I says, would you kindly go get stepped on by a big daddy?
Seems like Mother Goose has been playing around in your egg
salad.
This guy has such a way with words.
I got others.
Code yellow.
Oh!
I just told your brain to tell your heart to stop beating.
Not right off the bat, mind you.
The heart's a stubborn muscle, but it ain't that stubborn.
I hate this guy!
I hate him!
Oh.
Once you are free of Fontaine's control, then you can have
your
Yeah.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, wait.
Wait, yeah.
Okay, so there's two little sisters in this level.
But guys, I think we will call it here.
Perhaps.
I think this is a good place to stop.
Um.
Wow.
Oh my god, what a twist!
Oh, Atlas.
How could you betray me?
god atlas atlas is watching freaky wait so what my my health
really can't go any higher than this what I paid for
upgrades I'm getting I'm getting cheated right now atlas
never existed crazy what's that what's that manga panel from
Chainsaw Man that's just like, what's her name?
Makima is listening or something like that.
Would you kindly have a good night?
This is a great place to stop.
These next few areas are the finale.
Thank you for going the distance even though the bugs are a
great mean though.
Thanks for listening.
Yeah, Makima is listening.
It's such a good panel.
But yeah, let's save here.
How much longer than do you guys think I have at the game?
Like I said, Welcome to membership, thank you.
I'm frustrated that yesterday I didn't get nearly as far as
I wanted to.
About three hours or so.
Oh, okay.
Charpenters, thank you!
So one more stream.
one good length stream
the final segments of this game are decently long so maybe
if it's like a four hour stream four or five hours maybe
considering my pace six hours including all the hacking hey
hey I I held off I held off this time I held off and I also
I I auto hacked thing.
I'm a reformed hacker.
So, I will see if I finish.
It really depends on how much I get done this week as well.
Darko, thank you so much for the peak.
So glad the game worked better.
We all might have become big babies.
I was so sad because I was having so much fun with the game.
And so I was like, and I also felt really bad.
I felt like I was complaining so much And I was like This is
probably so not fun for people to watch Because it's just me
being like Ah stop it Ah It's not working Ah you know So I
was like But And also I'm glad we at least got to this part
It's so fun So Glad we got to see the twist and everything
So cool Yeah It was so much fun though That was not it I'm
glad.
The second game is better optimized.
The engine was far more stable by that point.
I also saw someone say that there's no hacking in the second
game.
So I gotta get my fill this time, right?
I'm a reformed hacker, says the girl who hacked a vending
machine after the city was rigged to explode.
Hacking our way to be a ghost in the machine.
I don't know about others, but I find...
the scuff to be entertaining.
I'm glad you guys I'm glad you can find it entertaining
whereas for me I'm like pulling my hair out.
Thank you for the fun streaming though.
Thank you!
Yeah, we did good progress today so that's awesome.
There is hacking in the second game but I don't think you'll
like it as much.
Oh really?
But that's okay.
This game is kind of rough.
Wow!
we're getting through it i'm getting you know i i get
through things in my own mental way so this game is a walk
in the park compared to system shock too that game hurts and
it hurts so good highly recommended well i feel like i would
have to play system shock one no thank you dan thank you so
much scuff entertain us you're stressing over it does not so
no there's some days like i said some days that i can like
kind of you know yesterday was so absurd i was just laughing
the whole time but today it was like frustrating because i
actively tried to fix it and then it decided to you know go
dookie on me so spending time with minto is the most
important part everything else is secondary thank you thank
you thank you thank you but yeah i i did save um it's kind
of lost because i didn't watch the other streams but it was
nice watching this stream minto streams always have my
spirit thank you thank you I will decide whether I finish I
really want, I mean, we're so close We're so close Maybe
instead of like a mega bonk
I'll think about it I can't do another double stream That's
the only issue I can't do, I would do a double stream But
I'm so I have so much more to do unfortunately So I cannot
uh but mega bonk i have on my list of things to play while
i'm away as well so uh for streams while i'm gone don't
think that mega bonk won't be played because it will be
system shock one got remade in 2023 highly recommend it oh
look into it or maybe i won't because i was told system
shock two hurts
they're a direct inspiration for bioshock highly recommend
the remake of System Shock 1 by 9,000.
Ah, I was wondering why you were recommending it.
Heads up, Minto, the longer you take on the next areas, the
more your health will go down.
Oh, good to know.
Especially because I'm a chronic explorer.
I like to just look at things just to look at them.
I'm like, let me just check the corner of this room.
Thanks for the stream, Minto.
Much love from me.
What?
She's incurable.
I know.
I just love to look at stuff.
I can't help it.
I can't help my sense of exploration.
I should have been born.
Well, actually, when was I born?
I'm dead.
I should have existed during the age.
I would have been the world's greatest explorer.
Call me in Mintaleo.
I would have been on the seas.
I would have found... I would have found...
I would have found every island.
I would have literally...
I would have found the One Piece by now.
Most of the developers who made System Shock also made
Bioshock so it's essentially a spiritual successor.
Oh!
I see.
babies like to explore so that's understandable it's fitting
since a baby is why you guys saying that about me i i i just
have a sense of wonder and and whimsy that's not because i'm
a baby it's because i'm an explorer i'm gonna i'm i'm i i'm
mapped to the seven c
Oh, Galileo, what?
Galileo sat around a lot.
Do you mean...
Oh, wait.
Who's Galileo?
Wait, did I mess them?
Did I mean Magellan?
I might have.
Your nonchalant bees makes me laugh each time.
Wouldn't a ghost birthday be on the day they died?
Well, yeah, I died October 1st, so...
Galileo was not Wait, which one was Galileo?
Mint Jelen makes more sense even.
Wait, what did Galileo do?
That guy was a philosopher, maybe?
Oh, he was an astronomer.
Open the schools!
Open the school!
Minto's a regular Tommy pickles.
No!
Minto is my favorite bit.
baby yeah Leo said the earth revolves around the Sun he
explored the stars he's still an explorer yeah daily dial
you get it you get it it works from home yeah and what am I
doing I'm sitting in my maid cafe right now exploring the
video games.
You think I leave?
Well, actually, I have been recently.
I have too soon.
But I don't get out.
If a ghost possesses their own zombie, did they technically
come back to live?
You know...
So, you can't really do that because, like, by the time
you're a ghost, like, by the time I am a fully, like, in
this presence, as you see me now, like even able of thoughts
and of everything, comprehending my feelings it's all bones
I would have to possess a skelly he explored the planets by
using math, okay I'm not Galileo yeah I start as a little
wisp and then I and I'm a little ball of energy That's what
I'm a baby.
Skelement.
So if you're doing the same thing, you didn't need to be
born back then because you're doing it now.
What's that meme?
Too late to explore the Seven Seas.
Too late to explore the...
Or too early to explore the universe.
Just in time to explore the inner machinations of my mind.
Born just in time for anime girls.
Yeah!
If you ever think, man, I'm in the bad timeline.
There is a worse timeline that doesn't have anime girls.
There is also a timeline where lizards...
i was there i know you say you're self-conscious about it
but the way you say really cute makes me smile yeah i just
get embarrassed about my stutter sometimes because it's
sometimes i don't know why why why i activate sometimes a
timeline where lizards
lizards.
This is a good timeline because it has Mito!
I only exist in this timeline.
Anyway.
Thank you guys so much.
I'm gonna go finish up some stuff that I need to work on.
Had fun.
Sorry, it's been so busy.
I've been wanting to like stream more and talk more after
the stream, but it's just like, I do so much in the day and
then i have to do more at night
so yeah there was a timeline where the lizard men went away
and have to return we're the meow tower creators you said
guide pro tags they must be they must be
sorry i'm catching up on messages i looked at discord and it
said i had seven messages Too many.
Oh.
Okay.
So popular.
At least it wasn't six messages.
Yeah.
How many from Steiner?
Zero.
Thank goodness.
I have to stop ripping on that guy.
He actually watches my streams.
sometimes he'll just message me and be like or yesterday he
was like he'll like tag me like a message like on discord
when I'm like trying to stream and I don't realize because I
just don't check discord really while I'm streaming except
in this case when I see I have a lot of messages and it was
him being yesterday he was just like yeah just restart it's
not your fault about the game It's like, I didn't see it
until like, so much later.
The guy's watching my stream sometimes.
This is so funny.
But yeah.
I know that this week is busy for me and there will be fewer
streams while I'm away.
But we'll talk lots while I'm gone and stuff too.
We, Dentsu too, we plan on having some off-collab stuff as
well.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I have Portal all lined up for you guys, so.
Panicking Lispa!
I spent years in speech therapy.
Your Lispa is cute and relatable.
I used to say those sick...
We...
Oh, wait, I used to say those sick we...
yellow flames don't be embarrassed oh the thing is too is
when i hear people with like you know like some sort of
speech something or other you know i i always think it's so
cute too but for myself i'm just like it's annoying so elmer
fud impediment speech impediment yeah yeah yeah not kidding
i was so locked in on work that i did not realize i had the
stream on mute for the watch the bot i guess i hope you got
a lot of work done thanks for having it open at least yeah
yeah yeah lots of me though everybody have a good day was
that big daddy i think i heard him have a good day have a
good night i will see you when i see you next let's all
travel to the timeline where lizards
Okay.
Somebody is hungry.
That's my tummy growling.
No, it's not.
I ate a burger right before stream.
I was too locked in.
Good.
Can I come along?
Yeah, we're all going.
Here we go.
Everybody.
Take my hand.
We're going.
We're going to the...
The dimension to the timeline that is lizards.
Ready?
Here we go!
Timeline that is lizards!
Lizards!
Guys.
I think I've done it.
Lizard.
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard,
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard,
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, lizard lizard lizard lizard lizard
lizard lizard lizard lizard lizard lizard lizard lizard